[Music]
yep that's colton haynes
thirsting over lil nos x in his new
music video
for industry baby fans are losing it
over the cameo and
we're losing it over that lip lick
[Music]
colton plays a cop who is supposed to be
standing watch over the prison little
nazex is escaping from in the video
but is watching the 22 year old singers
call me by your name music video
instead and lil nazex wasn't having it
so epic earlier this week lil nas
tweeted that the video for his single
was
not for kids and he was not wrong
colton's appearance may be the most pg
thing
about the industry baby video with jack
harlow as lil nas
broke boundaries with a sexy prison
shower dance scene
naked yes everyone was naked
lil nazax initially teased his new song
produced by kanye west and take a day
trip
with a two-minute clip of a court case
that poked fun
at his recent satan shoes fiasco with
nike
i want to make every song every drop in
my career like feel like
a moment where you can create a moment
in time you can do something
that you haven't done before each time
and i feel like that's amazing
in the clip he plays multiple roles the
judge
his attorney and himself are you gay
what does this have to do with the shoes
answer the question
and was sentenced to five years in
montero state prison
not for the issue with nike but for
being gay
lil nazex i sentenced you to five years
in montero state prison
the superstar also mocked the court
proceedings in the satan shoes case on
tick tock
me in court on monday pretending to not
care so that the judge falls in love
with me
and sets me free to clarify the nike
lawsuit over the satan's shoes
with a human drop of blood in them was
settled
months ago so this was all for show but
industry
baby seems to be lil nas's clap back at
the homophobic haters
in the most iconic way possible
especially after we see him
polishing his grammys and straightening
his framed
platinum record i thought it was way
more than i would have believed that it
would be but that's
life we got to push it forward we got to
keep going
the old town road singer has proved once
again
he's not a one-hit
long
wonder
[Music]